best friends janine bob and moyer and
sarah harker are in their hometown of
indianapolis these moms are dedicated to
connecting moms across the city and now
we're about to connect with them and
their love of indy watch this
hi drew i'm janine i'm sarah we are so
excited to take you around indianapolis
today to some of our favorite places
drew you're going to love it i cannot
wait did you just say drew as a drew
barrymore uh yeah
wow hello hey guys hey drew it's ryan
and jillian from indy now on fox 59.
yeah we were just going into work what
are you guys doing here we are going to
do a road trip for drew and take her to
some of our favorite spots around india
today awesome awesome yeah we're on a
tight schedule all right
okay
okay all right drew let's go
we're at holiday park it's one of the
gems of the indianapolis park system i
love the programming at holiday park
including yoga at the ruins which is
where we are today it's a little rainy
out thanks a lot indianapolis weather
but i think we'll still get a good class
in keep your right arm up take a big
stretch you're gonna love the garage
it's one of our favorite places to grab
something to eat there's a ton of
different vendors that you can choose
from and it was just recently voted one
of time magazine's number one places to
visit in the country don't forget we've
got one more place that we need to take
you any ideas
give me a hint okay ready go
let's go to the speedway
you're gonna love the indianapolis motor
speedway this is one of the biggest and
best attractions in the entire city it
is where racing happens all year round
indianapolis is the racing capital of
the world
drew we got your flag ready for you on
your camaro you're so ready
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today drew we've had a blast we have
loved showing you around indianapolis
and i think we need to take one last lap
here we go
[Music]
hi drew it's anna foster and i am
standing in front of wbz tv in my
hometown of boston i love boston because
it's rich in culture it's rich in
community and it's rich in innovation i
want to show you around boston so come
with me drew we're going to have a great
time
so we're right here in city hall plaza
in the heart of boston and i have a
special guest with me
drumroll
the mayor of boston mayor kim janey is
right here standing next to me i'm so
excited mayor janie tell us about boston
and why you love this city anna thank
you so much and a shout out to everyone
watching
i love my city this is the city that i'm
born and raised in i am a city girl
boston is a great world-class city a
city of innovation a city of first we
are the birthplace of america the
birthplace of public education first
library the best hospitals in the world
the best universities public space
beautiful parks and i'm just so grateful
and honored to serve as the first woman
mayor the first black mayor of boston it
is amazing wonderful thank you madam
mayor kim janey
well drew that's a little bit about my
hometown of boston i cannot wait for you
to visit see you soon
drew my name is jamie viback and i'm
standing here in front of cbs3 in my
hometown of philadelphia i'm so excited
to show you around today i'm a real
estate agent here in philadelphia and
one of my favorite things to do is to
show people around who are coming to
philadelphia for the very first time
let's say hi to jim and janelle from the
cbs channel three morning show good
morning hi drew welcome to philly yes
the city of brotherly love and sister
thanks for joining us
welcome to the fabulous wedding terminal
market that's over 150 years old there's
more than 80 vendors everything from
buying gifts to pretzels to cookies to
ice cream i love coming here andrew i
cannot wait to show you what's inside
you're going to love it you need to
check this place out best bagels best
lofts best cream cheese in the world
love this place rehearsals east side
best sandwiches anything is anybody in
the mood for cheese because if you are
then you've got to come to the real
cheese shop you'll find everything that
you want
here we are at the art museum the iconic
art museum at the end of our tour i hope
that you enjoyed yourself as much as i
did i love showing philly around
especially to viewers and i hope that
you enjoyed it as well drew i'm a huge
fan dating all the way back to et give
me a call when you come to town
[Music]
you